Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom because
these two lovebirds couldn't help but
bring us along on their Hollywood date
sharing a sweet kiss a hug and a red
carpet snuggle for all the world to see
and whatever Orlando whispered in
Katie's ears sure made her laugh what
did you whisper in her ear before
secrets of Secrets come on
[Music]
what the engaged couple didn't keep
secret this moment from their limo how
many times have we done this video to
the red carpet just a supportive
girlfriend tonight that's all that's my
role the future mrs. blue was radiant in
a pinkish dress from Tom Ford's 2019
collection the gown with chain straps
cost almost six thousand dollars he did
say something really sweet and interview
the other day you said it's the little
things that matter what's one little
thing you've done for her lately to show
you to show her we have a blackboard and
we write messages of love you were
celebrating at the premiere of Orlando's
first American TV series carnival row
Calista Salama he's a cop in the Amazon
Prime fantasy show that's already been
picked up for season two it's exciting
to be a part of something that feels
like it's a story that people hopefully
will enjoy and that's what we're doing
it for right fill all your fantasies if
you have any left I'm right here
you